welcome back to the matrix math series
today we're gonna be talking about
multiplication it's a little weird and
you just have to memorize a few things
to get it right so let's jump into it so
you have a matrix named a and it looks
like this will just give some random
numbers two three four five that's
obviously a two by two matrix and I'll
do a B that is a alright let's make it a
two by three so two rows three columns
seven one zero and looks like a tier and
that's how that's how you should feel
about matrix multiplication just to shed
a little tear to another seven and a
eight so we have a 2x2 named a and a 2x3
okay with the name of of B to multiply
these together say if you the result is
called a B so it'll look something like
and you can multiply them together if
the columns and the first one so it'll
be this number two columns is equal to
the rows and the second one so this here
and that's the only way if these don't
match then a B is considered undefined
so if this were a three by three then we
tried them all a two by two by three by
three would get undefined there would be
no result you don't have to do any
operations the answer is just undefined
so that's actually the easy case but
when these do match as in this case
they're both twos then you get a
resulting matrix and the size of the
resulting matrix is well you basically
just cross these out and you get a two
by three so when you are allowed to
multiply them the resulting matrix is
going to be the size of
these two so it could be any varying
result if this was a four and this was a
seven this was a four by two and a two
by 7 you would end up with a four by
seven
for example well we're keeping it simple
here we're gonna end up with a two by
three so let's go ahead and multiply
these together and we'll get into the
meat potatoes of doing this so basically
what you do is you take the row of the
first one in times by the column of the
second one per element so we're gonna
get a two by three so we're gonna say a
times B that's B equals and we're gonna
get a resulting matrix we already know
just by looking at the sizes it's gonna
be a two by three I made this purposely
big so we're gonna need spaces so we're
gonna have to fill in each of these
elements spots and things a little
underline areas being element spots so
sweet a first row with three columns one
two three second row with also three
columns so to get this first area we're
going to multiply multiply this first
row by this first column and you start
with the first one so first element here
times first element two times seven and
then you add it to the rest and you
basically continue on so next it's gonna
be three times two times two I guess I
could write it kind of like the other
one this parenthesis just means we're
multiplying by it so that is gonna be
the result of the first element there is
this all together which of course is 14
two times seven fourteen and then plus
three times two is six so we'd end up
with a 20 in this first element spot
I'll just write that above real quick
and for this next element spot so when
you get to this next one here we're
still in the first row so so gonna be
multiplying along for Israel but now
we're in the second column so we're
gonna be multiplying it against the
second column so it's gonna be 2 times 1
which is just 2 so I'm just gonna leave
it up line 2 and leave out the times 1
save a little space and then 3 times 7
which of course is 21 when I was go
ahead and put 3 times 7 there so it's
gonna end up being 21 plus 2 so we're
gonna end up with a 23 in this element
spot that's 3 there we go
all right and for this last spot here
we're still in the first row and now
we're on the third column the TR column
2 times 0 which is of course the 0 I'm
just gonna put things here or there and
then 3 times 8 which is of course 24 and
we're gonna end up with the result 24
and I'm gonna write that above because
it's quite obvious and we'll do these
last ones and to do those we're gonna
move now to the second row since we're
on the second row and we're going to
times it against the columns 4 times 7 4
times 7 which is of course gonna be 28
and 5 times to add that 10 so we're
gonna get 28 plus 10 that's gonna be 38
and then we'll continue on 4 times 1
still on the second row now on the
second column so you see kind of see how
that lines up so that's one way of
remembering it I always do rows types
columns and it's the same way when
you're speaking about the order of your
matrices so that's one way to remember
it but often if you haven't done them in
a while you you'll need a memory jog and
that's that's pretty normal with these
because they're just long winded and
then 5 times 7 which is 35 so then we
get 35 plus 4 and we end up 39 in this
spot
and over here we get a four times zero
which is just gonna be zero plus five
times eight which is gonna be 40 we just
end up with a 40 there so there's our
resulting matrix it's a two by three
with those numbers twenty twenty three
twenty four thirty eight thirty one and
forty and it came from these small
numbers so that's pretty much it for
matrix math and multiplication there's a
few laws I wanted to talk about real
quick let's create a new layer here
yes societal law and I could do examples
but I'm not going to because it it's
just gonna take too long
basically says if you're multiplying a B
and C it's gonna equal the same thing as
a B okay that's too large let's shrink
that down a little there we go
associative law basically says a time's
the result of BC is gonna be the same
thing as the result of a B times C so
that holds true and multiplication
another law second one left distributed
law just read you Jude Law and that is
basically when you might have heard
distributive before but it's C and a
times B plus C is equal to the same as C
a B multiplied together plus BC
multiplied together and once again we
ran out of room so let me shrink this
down a little more there we go so that
is the left distributive law and of
course you might be used to seeing this
furies to algebra this would be a times
B plus a times C that holds true and the
third and final law is the right a
distributive law
going to put those so I don't have to
type it again distributive law right
distributive law and that's gonna look
pretty similar it's B plus C times a is
equal to B times a plus C times a so
those are the laws and real quick just
one last thing going back to this it's
really important to note that if you
flip these around you don't get the same
result
like if this was B times a it would be a
very different thing well you couldn't
even do it because if we flip these
around it would be this two wouldn't
match with our this three wouldn't match
with this two so we've been undefined
but sometimes you'll get a case where
you can flip them around and you can
also do another multiplication but
you'll end up with a completely
different result okay that's gonna do it
for this episode it was a long one but
this is an important one if you're doing
matrix math make sure you understand
this the rows times column thing and how
they add together alright thanks for
watching catch you guys in the next
episode keep learning keep laughing
living life and don't rage goodbye